trees that are part planted on either
side of a street light and stop sign
there there's another tree that's right
next to a fire hydrant there's sidewalk
that's busted up you know 100 feet away
all of these things to me seem like a
higher priority than squash
Los Angeles a city full of overgrown
weave like this and litter like this and
totally messed up sidewalks like this so
why did city officials crackdown on a
front yard that looks like this my name
is angel tagger
I've lived in South LA for just about
three years now all of these plants
everything the bricks the trees the
plants and all of these fruit trees had
to go angel received this citation from
the city telling her to get rid of her
garden within 48 hours or else start
paying fines I was upset you know I
really can't explain why we were singled
out because there are other problems
that definitely would deserve more
priority but he felt it was important
for us to take everything out within 48
hours so it was a priority for him
luckily the same group who helped her
plant the garden rushed to her defense
they called themselves la green grounds
if the city wanted angel to restore the
Parkway to what it was before it would
be an unsightly weedy strip of land and
this is true in many areas of Los
Angeles we're using a space that
normally we just go waste it and under
use they've run into problems with the
city before and it's been fighting for
years for the simple right to plant
front yard gardens on the parkways the
person who owns the adjacent to the
sidewalk property owns the Parkway the
city does not own the Parkway but the
city has an interest in it there are
water lines and other things that affect
the city in the case of angels garden I
really don't see why she was cited
there's nothing oversized is obstructing
view in fact the car would not be able
to park to allow a passenger off at this
intersection I think that sometimes they
set their priorities to appear to be
productive and going after
issues that are they believe or may
perceive that are easy to solve and
either bring revenue into the city or to
just appear to be busy for now the city
is suspended enforcement of the
ordinance an angel gets to keep regarded
the bigger concern is to get the
ordinance change because this is a
growing movement bureaucracy has gotten
things to the point where it's very
complicated all these different
departments needs to review and approve
and send it back for signatures or
whatever but really what we're asking
for is something very simple is to
update the acceptable planting list to
include fruits and vegetables it's an
idea that's spreading and I would hate
for anyone else to have to go through
the hassle that I went through